[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
hi so my talk is called immutability or
putting the dream machine to work so
I've been a front-end developer for
eight years now I was at the New York
Times for four I recently left to join
up with a company called cognate echt
their consultancy and they also have a
database and a cognate act I think we
believe that a lot of software is far
too complex and there's ways to achieve
a lot more simplicity in the type of
systems that we write one way to achieve
simplicity is through immutability
by embracing immutability so cognitive
stewards closure and closure script I'm
the lead maintainer of clojurescript
those languages emphasize immutability
we also have a database product called
de Tomic which is a immutable relational
database I'm not actually going to talk
about any of those things today or only
we'll only talk about them a little bit
the thing that I really want to talk
about today is the dream machine so if
you have not seen this book or
encountered this book this should be
number one on your reading list if you
are involved in interactive computing in
any way shape or form this was
recommended to were recommended by Alan
Kay as one of the best histories of how
interactive computing came to be it will
make you laugh it will make you cry and
if you have anything with you eyes it
will fill you with a sense of wonder
so JCR Licklider was a psychologist who
at the time realized that there was not
a serious enough perspective on the role
of human psychology and human factors in
computing systems also a lot of people
didn't believe interactive computing
systems would be of any utility
whatsoever and he really paved the way
through
to make sure that research institutions
were you know putting the time and
effort into discovering the results of
you know interactive computing so he is
most famous for two essays one of the
famous ones is called the man computer
symbiosis
so Licklider basically predicted my talk
fifty-four years ago I was going through
this paper for the actually the first
time two days ago and he says something
very specific which I'm going to talk
about quite a bit today this talk is a
bit of a little bit of history a little
bit of data structures and a little bit
of examples so in this paper he he sort
of lays out what are the types of
hardware and software things that are
going to pave the way for interactive
systems he saw computing as a way to
augment the human intellect so he says
in this paper the tree memory scheme is
inefficient for small memories but it
becomes increasingly efficient and using
available storage space as memory size
increases the attractive features of the
scheme are these number one the
retrieval process is extremely simple
given the argument entered the standard
initial register with the first
character pick up the address of the
second then go to the second register
and pick up the addresses of the third
if two arguments have initial characters
in common they use the same storage
space for these characters and I'm going
to actually talk about this quite a bit
here we have several people that
benefited from the culture that
Licklider created John McCarthy Rees
received considerable funding he is the
inventor of Lisp artificial intelligence
interpreters functional programming
garbage collection all things that are
critical for doing anything that you
guys are doing today he was a
mathematician at the time using
computers was extremely difficult
he believed that computer actually
programming the computer itself should
be a real-time interactive activity you
can thank him for console the
interactive console that's that's
definitely due to John McCarthy to his
right is Ed fredkin he was a Caltech
dropout at 19
went to the US Air Force was a fighter
pilot and then when he was very young
was pivotal and in hacking these early
computers to do impossible things to
build interactive systems
Ede fred can also invented the tree and
that spelled TR IE and that's what we're
gonna talk a bit about so Alan Kay is
another important figure he also
benefited from the culture that
Lickliter created Alan Kay what well
understood
John McCarthy's ideas he built an
interactive programming language but on
top of that he sort of erected the
edifice that we are all familiar with
today around object-oriented programming
as well as blazing the trail around what
we consider modern user interfaces so
here's an image that I think is very
inspiring a big goal of his was that
computing should be simpler that it
should be available to people at a very
young age
here are some boys and girls and they're
interacting with a live small talk
programming environment and they're
doing things that you know we're I mean
they were very lucky right they were
they were they were experiencing the
future of computing when most people
were still doing basic right there's a
really great article I recommend reading
this is an article that I found on the
Atari archive it's more its Marion gold
Goldeen Marion golden and she was 11
years old and she was lucky enough to
experience a Xerox Paul out Xerox Alto
and small talk and she describes when
she's like 12 years old what it was like
to program one of these machines so she
she but directly benefitted from the
dream machine she's actually has for
years been a UI programmer at Apple and
she went off to do this because of her
experiences with the small talk
environment anyways you can fire up a
small talk environment today there's an
open-source one called squeak it's quite
cool if you open the system browser
which uncovers the entire internals of
that system you will encounter something
which is very familiar to JavaScript
programmers model-view-controller trig
Vereen Skagen adele goldberg and others
at Xerox PARC invented NBC well 35 35
years ago
longshadow people are still talking
about this stuff I would actually argue
we haven't really advanced much beyond
it but that's okay
because at an abstract level NBC is a
sound separation of concerns we want
users to be able to interact with their
domain we want to have intuitive
representations that domain and as
programmers we want to coordinate that
abstract domain and those abstract
visual representations such that the
user has a pleasant experience but I
would argue that implementations leave
much to be desired that's having worked
with a variety of mbc's over the years
and that's because they're erected on
top of stateful objects you have
stateful models you have stateful
controllers and you have stateful views
and so the crazy I'm the idea that I'm
going to throw out as I think that
Licklider was correct if you build your
user interfaces around trees really cool
things happen so trees so this is the
data structure part of the talk I'm just
gonna reuse some slides because these
slides are amazing they were done by
Zach Hollan at hacker school he's a
facilitator there he put these slides
together for Strange Loop and they're
just so good there's absolutely no
reason for me to come up with my own so
regardless of whether you like
functional programming a lot it's not
very important but all these ideas apply
if you like object-oriented programming
but we need to at least understand how
these data structures came to be and why
functional programmers like them in
order to understand how we might use
them if we prefer the object-oriented
approach so functional programmers they
like immutable values they don't like
stateful objects and when you change
something you just return a new value
and as JavaScript programmers you guys
are already well aware of this
you have numbers in JavaScript they are
thank goodness
immutable strings you're lucky not every
dynamic primary language had add
immutable strings you have immutable
strings so what functional programmers
want is that yes we know that if you add
one and one and we get to that doesn't
doesn't change the other ones right so
functional programmers also want this
behavior from collections so if I had a
key value to a map I get a new map and
the old map is not destroyed so as
JavaScript programmers you're extremely
used to destroying data on destroying
the past and we don't have to do that
and I'll demonstrate how this can be
done and so this is where the term
persistent comes from not persistent in
the sense of like you're going to record
it to a database but persistent in the
sense that you're not destroying
previous values and they're very fast
and this is actually relatively a recent
development Okazaki talked about purely
functional data structures but that you
know there
okay and they work they have good paper
complexity bounds a man named Phil
Bagwell who was EPFL where Scala was
invented he did initial research in the
early 2000s and how you could have
really high-performance persistent data
structures and they were further
modified by rich icky and actually it
was really closure that showed that they
could perform well on modern hardware
but they might that might sound really
advanced but I wanted to show you that
it's not scary oh I bet almost everyone
here in this room knows what a linked
list is and linked lists have the same
properties that we like about trees so
in a linked list here's a list with four
things in it and we store it in a
variable X well I can cons some value
onto the head of that and I can store
that in a variable Y and now I have two
values right and they share more than
50% of memory right they represent two
distinct values but they share more than
50% of memory I can take the tail of X
and cons e onto that now I have three
distinct list values and they all share
more than 50% of their memory so this is
a scalable idea this idea is called
structural sharing so sharing structure
gives us space efficiency but less
obvious is that actually gives you
computational efficiency so you if you
use structural sharing you can do these
immutable values and you can update just
a part of it and it will be efficient so
fill bag wall innovated this space again
he came up with this thing called the
arraignment try sort of tree hash array
hash array map tree rich Hickey took
that and modified it quite a bit in a
very clever way and he invented
something called the bitmap vector tree
so I know that everybody here knows what
an array is so a bitmap vector tree is
like an array it's its high-performance
random access and you can append to the
end quickly as well so the way that they
work as data lives in the leaves
it's a prefixed tree and remember
Licklider was talking about this in 1960
it uses a prefect it's a prefixed tree
to find a particular value and it's but
it's done in a bitwise way to make that
more visual so in in the in the tree of
a persistent vector you have an array of
arrays so at the root you have to pick
some fixed size say for and then every
element of that points to an array
which was also the same size and then
those arrays point to more arrays that
are the same size finally you're going
to hit a leaf node where you have actual
values okay this sounds kind of
interesting but how the hell do you look
up anything in this so imagine we wanna
get 100 sixth element so we can do this
really cool trick that represents a
binary number we can use bit masking to
find that thing so we can bit mask off
the first two bits this tells us to look
at look at index 1 we can bit-bit mask
the next two bits that get takes us the
next level look at index 2 bit mask
again finally it says the value you're
looking for is that index 2 and that's
106 so if you know anything about modern
JavaScript engines array axises and bit
shifting is about as fast as you can get
this is going to do this is going to be
the engine optimize this in pretty wild
ways which I will show that - but what
about update so this is where the
structural sharing comes into play if I
want to update for example I want to
replace 106 with the string foo how much
work do we have to do we only have to
clone the arrays on the path that
changed all other paths that weren't
involved in the change don't need to be
updated so that's how much work we have
to do to to update that thing and none
of the other nodes are going to change
they all stay the same so this is where
the the structural sharing we saw with
linked lists happens with trees so
you're probably thinking well the for
this seems like a weird number to pick
for the length and of course after
empirical testing it turns out that 32
is a really good number on modern
hardware you do a bunch of tests and 32
works out the best in terms of how
expensive is it to update versus how
quickly we can look something out ok
just to give you a sense of how good a
such a wide branching factor is 32 to
the seventh power that's 34 billion
elements on a 64-bit OS with a 64-bit VM
where the values are 64-bit if you do
that in a regular JavaScript array
that's 256 gigabytes of RAM I don't
think anybody in this room has a laptop
with that much memory to update
something in this data structure only
requires seven array updates to access
anything at most you need seven array
accesses and in some bit operations
okay so that's a lot of talk let's see
some let's see some numbers so this is a
recent build of v8 I'm I've exported all
the functionality and closure script by
a library called Mori which is available
on NPM as well as for the browser if you
want to do that so what I do is I build
an array and I add one mill I just
pushed one million elements to a
nighttime that and then I do this with a
persistent vector and I just calculate
the average well it looks like eighty
three milliseconds on this particular
machine and then we have an average of
about 288 for persistent vectors so it
should already be shocking because it's
this is not an order of magnitude slower
right this is about a little bit more
than three times slower that's already
cool there are many applications that
could benefit from these data structures
that don't need just the craziest amount
of perf I'm going to show something a
little bit crazier so we've been doing
persistent data structures for seven
years now enclosure and clear scripts
we've gotten more and more clever about
what optimizations you can do so you
guys might be familiar with object
freeze so of course all all of our data
structures are already front effectively
frozen but we have a corresponding
operation called thumb rule it's called
transient but we imagine it's like
object thaw and we can get in oh one
time a mutable version of the persistent
thing and we can also make it persistent
again in one time so how does a
transient vector compared to a immutable
array it's faster to build a persistent
vector than it is to mutate immutable
array so that's pretty crazy to show
that this is true on on engines other or
not faster but the performance is about
the same or not so bad for other
JavaScript engines this is a recent
build of JavaScript core it's not it's
not significantly slower right so we but
we have we have all this all these
magical properties that arrays don't
have and we can achieve their
performance of mutable arrays okay so
that's that's awesome so this is this is
because so many people have been
building the dream machine for us right
just
so much research has gone into
optimizing dynamic programming languages
and I got really excited because
recently WebKit sort of kicked up the
notch again I felt like things were
stagnating a bit with their FTL JIT
which is a fourth tier and that tier is
going to absolutely love the type of
code that's involved in doing these
kinds of data structures so there's more
excitement to come nick bray talked on
thursday about opening up the door to
shared memory parallel ism so closure
skippers already ready for that
clojurescript data structures are
already locked free so you can do
parallel operations on them without
locks okay so hopefully you're excited
about trees and you're convinced that
maybe Licklider had a good idea in 1960
so I want to see well what does this
mean for interactive programs so I built
a library five months ago called ohm
maybe some of you heard of it it it
basically marries are the suite of tree
based data structures with react and it
turns out that these are a really good
pair and let's talk really briefly why
so we can now represent our application
state as one giant immutable value and
then react says oh well you can apply a
function to that and we're going to
compute some virtual Dom which is
another value and now if I update my
immutable app state and I get a new
value I can apply that function again
and react will produce some new virtual
Dom and the way that react works is it
applies a very clever diffing algorithm
on the on these two virtual Dom's
and then that creates a minimal change
set but what's fascinating about this is
that what happens if we flip V 1 and V 0
for free react will give us the reverse
change set right for free so this means
that we can do undo redo trivially you
can you can jump or to an arbitrary
point in time you can also do things it
makes actually computing Delta's faster
you can do it makes that which makes
synchronization simpler for example if
you want to rollback your app state on
an error you can just jump back to the
previous application state the snapshot
you don't have to manually reconstruct
what your app looked like before the
error occurred lots of cool stuff it's
not just about undo and redo which some
people get confused about
okay so let's so I it's it's most fun to
show an example that I did not write so
I said
I did a version up to do NBC with ohm
and I said I think I can do undo pretty
simply and I was able to do it
and non-invasively I did not change any
of my to do MBC code I did in an
external change and it was five lines of
code to add undo over the entire state
of the to-do MVC application so this guy
a table tainha skyjacked Scheidler said
well maybe maybe David know is pulling
my chain here is this this is actually
really work for a less trivial thing
than to do MVC so he decided decided to
build a 64 by 64 pixel editor the pixel
surface the frame is represented as an
immutable vector and that's 4096 values
in there that represent pixels so let's
see this guy in action so I can I can
select the color here and then I can you
know start drawing some things on to you
or let's resize that on the right you
should see the history accumulating I
can go over here and I can click undo
and click redo I can I can scrub and you
see the preview on the left oops
to do that and I can you know I can I
could you do this forever I've done it
you know I've done like 200 levels of
undo and the app is still responsive
good memory usage it doesn't slow down
so that's pretty cool so how complicated
was him was it was it for him to
actually implement that functionality
this is the entire code for undo redo
the preview as well as exporting it as
an animated gif these are very simple
functions it's about 60 lines of code
this is a nightmare to do in a mutable
system if you've ever tried that before
it's not fun and how much memory does it
use so if you took an array and you
cloned it 100 times and you because you
wanted to preserve the state of your app
of your frames and you updated one pixel
it takes about 1.7 megabytes to do this
if you do the same thing with a
persistent vector and you snapshot at
100 times you randomly updated a pixel
each time it takes two tenths of a
megabyte it's almost an order of
magnitude memory savings to use
persistent data structures for this
okay so we're getting we're nearing
towards the end so I I use closure and I
use closure script but I also do a lot
of JavaScript but I understand that a
lot of people don't want to do closure
script Lisp is still too crazy for a lot
of people so I spent some time about two
years ago exporting all of closure
scripts data structures as well as the
entire standard library for interacting
with them in a library called Mori if
you want to experiment with like what
type of user interfaces can we build
given the availability of really fast
really expressive persistent data
structures I highly recommend checking
it out I've tried for the most part to
follow conventions that are exist in
lodash and an underscore or what have
you but it does a lot more I mean there
are a lot of data structures we have
sets hashmaps sorted sets sorted maps
the persistent vectors I talked about
and some other things as well and I
actually there's a lot actually there's
a lot of cool possibilities here around
sweet Jas and Mori people have done some
experiments where by using sweet Jas
macros you can instead of having arrays
becoming arrays you can create
persistent vectors and if you have a
little object literal syntax instead it
will produce a a persistent hash map so
that's it hopefully that didn't take too
much time oh thanks
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]